this is your weather now good afternoon  with john langler at the anchor dash  nathan talendam in the 8 news 9 weather  center you're looking at all sunshine  here and it is going to be another warm  one we're talking about 97 degrees at  the top of the hour just a little breeze  though we're five degrees cooler than we  were 24 hours ago all sunshine and i  think that's where it's going to stay  for a little while your weather  headlines some afternoon breezes temps  under 100 and the eight day forecast  we'll also talk about a well a quote  from  all time favorite singer songwriters  john prine who wrote summer's ends  around the bend just flying 8 news now  at noon starts right now